Willkommen bei der Tourismus-Militärakademie
Ich bin Carl Marcus Reisner Ich bin der Leiter
der Forschungs- und
Entwicklungsabteilung der Akademie und bin derzeit
Kommandeur der Wachmannschaft in Wien.
Heute in unserem Brief werden wir uns das
ansehen  Krieg um die Ukraine und wir werden einen
Blick auf die ersten identifizierten Lehren und die nächsten Herausforderungen werfen, die
wir in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten erwarten oder sehen könnten.
Es ist ein Tag 324 und es ist ein
Update des Konflikts,
es ist wichtig, das alles zu verstehen  Meine
Bewertung befindet sich in einem
Koordinatensystem, das durch verschiedene Domänen definiert ist,
also haben wir die
Weltraumdomäne, die Luftdomäne, die Meeresdomäne
, die Landdomäne und natürlich die
Cyber- und die Informationsdomäne.
Sie können also sehen, dass alle in diesen
unterschiedlich sind  Domänen passieren Dinge
und alle diese interagieren
miteinander,
also müssen wir zunächst
zwischen der taktischen, der operativen und
der strategischen Ebene unterscheiden, die technische Ebene
bedeutet, dass wir sicher sind  Apon-Systeme wie die
Hymer-Systeme und was für
Fähigkeiten sie haben Operational Level
bedeutet Offensive also die
Offensive Kiev
Harkif oder Cason und die Solicit-Ebene ist
die Ebene, die entscheidend ist, wenn es
um die Frage geht, wie lange man
damit eigentlich einen Krieg führen kann  In diesem bestimmten
Fall zum Beispiel die Angriffe von
russischer Seite auf die kritische
Infrastruktur der Ukraine.
Beginnen wir also mit der taktischen Ebene.
Wir wissen, dass die Russen 2014
in die Ukraine eingedrungen sind, indem sie das System der
taktischen Gruppe des Bataillons benutzten. Sie
taten dasselbe im Februar 2022  Aber das
Problem war, dass diese Struktur nicht
ausreichte, um weiter in
den Tod des Landes anzugreifen. Das größte
Problem war der Mangel an Infanterie auf der
anderen Seite. Die Ukrainer verwendeten
sehr ausgefeilte Techniken und
Taktiken und sie verwendeten auch moderne
Waffensysteme  wie Drohnen oder bestimmte
Arten von Artilleriemunition, die
der russischen Seite hohe Verluste zugefügt haben,
also ist es wichtig  Um zu verstehen,
dass die taktischen Techniken und
Verfahren entscheidend sind, wenn es um
die taktische Ebene geht, ist
die nächste Ebene die operative Ebene.
Hier können wir also sehen, dass
die Ukrainer zur Überraschung vieler Experten
dem Russen hohe Verluste zufügen konnten
Neben mehr oder weniger drei
erfolgreichen Operationen, nämlich der
Operation in der Gegend von Kiew,
Harkif und Kershaw, auf der anderen Seite, konnte die
russische Seite nicht
alle Fußstapfen gewinnen, die sie zu
Beginn des Konflikts erreichen wollte, aber
sie konnte es auch  entschieden gegen die ukrainische
Seite zu kämpfen, wie wir
in meiner Rückumfrage schwere tolenska Lisa
Schansk gesehen haben, und natürlich hat es im Moment
unsere Schlagstimmung sortiert,
so dass es eine Weile gedauert hat, sich anzupassen,
aber die russische Seite konnte sich anpassen
Im Kampf auf der operativen Ebene ist also
Flexibilität etwas, was sehr
wichtig ist. Auf dieser Ebene ist
die strategische Ebene wichtig, wenn es
um die Frage geht, wie
lange kann  Sie führen den Krieg, und wie Sie
sehen können
, stellten die Russen fest,
dass sie Probleme auf
operativer Ebene hatten, aber durch den Einsatz ihrer
strategischen Mittel
wie Langstreckenbomber oder sogar Drohnen
und Marschflugkörper konnten sie dem
großen Schaden zufügen  Ukrainische
kritische Infrastruktur, das bedeutet, dass
die Russen am Anfang
mit ihren Angriffen ziemlich erfolgreich waren, aber die
erfolgreichsten Angriffe
begannen natürlich am 10. Oktober, als
sie begannen, die kritische
Infrastruktur der ukrainischen Seite anzugreifen, und
bis heute ist die ukrainische Seite es
kämpfen immer noch mit dem Einsatz ihrer
Luftverteidigungsanlagen, um die kritischen
Infrastrukturstandorte zu verteidigen, daher ist die Dauer
eines Konflikts sehr wichtig, wir haben im
Moment etwa L 11 Monate,
also lassen Sie uns jetzt über die wichtigsten Kampffähigkeiten sprechen,
von denen es mehrere gibt und wie Sie können  Sehen Sie, wie all
diese Fähigkeiten miteinander interagieren,
und es ist wichtig, über
Ressourcen und Fähigkeiten zu verfügen  Beginnen wir in jedem
dieser Felder
mit dem ersten, um einen erfolgreichen Angriff auf einen Feind zu ermöglichen, und das ist die Vorbereitung.
Wie wir gesehen haben,
waren die Ukrainer zu Beginn des Konflikts gut vorbereitet, als
es um den russischen Angriff ging, ein gutes
Beispiel  ist die Schlacht um Kiew, wo die
Ukrainer den russischen Vormarsch stoppen
konnten, indem sie den europäischen Fluss überschwemmten und die Brücken zerstörten
, und durch den
Einsatz von Artilleriesystemen können wir
der russischen Seite hohe Verluste zufügen
und auch den Einsatz kleiner Einheiten in
Special  Streitkräfte, die die Russen im
ganzen Konvoi treffen und ihn
über eine große Entfernung ausbreiten, konnten
der russischen Seite hohe Verluste zufügen.
Daher ist die richtige Planung entscheidend, wenn es
um den Krieg geht.
Das nächste wichtige Projekt ist Projekt, also
bedeutet Projekt, wie es ist  Es ist möglich, einen
stetigen Fluss von Kräften und Ressourcen für
Ihre Kampftruppe aufrechtzuerhalten, und wir haben gesehen,
dass auch die russische Seite in der Lage ist,
sich anzupassen, weil z  So
konnten beispielsweise die russischen
Truppen aus dem Raum Kiew über 1000
Kilometer 50 bis 60 000 Soldaten per
Zug in den Donbass abziehen, wo sie
in der
zweiten Phase des Konflikts auf der
anderen
Seite mit einem neuen Haupteinsatz begannen  Die Ukrainer waren in der Lage,
alle eingehenden Ressourcen, alle
Waffensysteme von Polen in die Ukraine und zu
ihren Streitkräften zu leiten, wo sie
tatsächlich gegen die Russen im Kampf eingesetzt wurden,
daher ist der Schwung sehr wichtig, man
muss immer einen stetigen Schwung haben,
wenn es darum geht  Kommt es zum Kampf,
so ist die nächste Fähigkeit, sich zu engagieren, sich zu engagieren.
Bedeutet, dass Kriegseinsätze auch
Angriffe und die Fähigkeit zum Angriff bedeuten.
Es ist interessant zu sehen, dass sich
der Konflikt nach den dritten Wochen des Konflikts
sehr schnell auf eine Weise bewegte,
die von vielen nicht erwartet wurde  von
Experten und das war der Einsatz massiver
Artilleriesysteme von beiden Seiten, und wie
Sie hier sehen können, ist es wichtig, das zu
verstehen, wenn es um
en geht  Bei der Messung anderer mit Artilleriesystemen
ist der Faktor Geschwindigkeit
entscheidend, und wir haben auf
ukrainischer Seite eine hohe Flexibilität und eine
Befehls- und Kontrollstruktur gesehen, die
es ermöglicht
, sofort nach der
Erkennung eines Ziels Verluste auf
russischer Seite zuzufügen  Auf der anderen Seite übernahmen die
Russen, die ein sehr zentralisiertes
Anforderungssystem hatten,
die Zeit, bis die ähm
angeforderten
Artilleriesysteme tatsächlich
auf der ukrainischen Seite arbeiteten. Daher ist es wichtig
zu verstehen, dass die Geschwindigkeit ein entscheidender
Faktor ist, wenn es darum geht,
die nächste Fähigkeit zu schützen  am
ende der zweiten phase war die
situation so, dass es nicht klar war, ob
die russen die ukraine im
inneren durchsetzen würden, wegen des einsatzes
ihrer massiven artilleriesysteme, und mit
der lieferung des amerikanischen heima-
systems war es möglich, diese einzusetzen
Raketen, um die russischen Amity-Pole zu entdecken,
und es dauerte eine Weile, bis die
Russen
die Amity-Pole und t zerstreuten
Um sie zu schützen, benutzen sie das Pantry-
System, um ihre Amity-Stöcke
gegen die ankommenden Raketen zu verteidigen. Dies war
erfolgreich, sodass die Amerikaner
ein anderes Waffensystem einführen mussten, und dies
war die Anti-Radar-Rakete, die von diesen
Raketen zerstört
wurde  Natürlich war
es den Hymer-Systemen wieder möglich, Ziele
auf russischer Seite anzugreifen,
daher sind präzise Waffen in dem Konflikt sehr wichtig,
und natürlich aufgrund
der Tatsache, dass diese Waffen
gegen neue Ressourcen wirken können und Sie Ressourcen haben
müssen, wenn Sie möchten  wie
einen Konflikt für eine längere Zeit zu kämpfen
die nächste Fähigkeit ist aufrechterhalten Wir werden
auf Halt schauen, wenn wir uns die
Streitkräfte und natürlich die Munition ansehen, damit wir
wissen, dass beide Seiten zu Beginn
des Konflikts bestimmte Fähigkeiten hatten
, die die Invasionsmacht war und  Das war
die verteidigende Streitmacht Die verteidigende
Streitmacht konnte über zwei Monate hinweg
erfolgreich gegen die Invasionstruppe
von russischer Seite kämpfen, bis dies der Fall war  Im Sommer
verlor die Ukraine laut ukrainischen Quellen etwa 50 Prozent ihrer
Ausrüstung,
daher war es wichtig, dass neue
Ausrüstung hereinkam, und der Westen lieferte
etwa 1 400 Panzer, Infanterie-
Kampffahrzeuge und Artilleriesysteme, und diese
Ausrüstung ermöglichte es der Ukraine
, erneut zu starten  neue Offensive Inner
Cason und auch Hakif
, das heißt die Ukraine
erhielt viel Ausrüstung, die es
ihr ermöglichte, auf
der anderen Seite weiter anzugreifen, die Russen hatten auch
hohe Verluste, aber auch hier waren sie
immer in der Lage und in der Lage, ihre
Lücken zu schließen  Wenn wir neue Ressourcen aus
Russland einbringen, und natürlich auch, wenn wir
uns die Munition ansehen, die wir sehen können, sind
ihre Ressourcen, die der russische Standort
hat, offensichtlich ziemlich größer als die
Ukraine im Inneren, es wird gesagt, dass die
Russen etwa 17 Millionen Artilleriegeschosse haben,
sieben Millionen davon  Sie haben
während der Kämpfe in den letzten
Monaten etwa 3,4 Millionen pro
Jahr produziert, das heißt, es ist genug
verfügbar  Wenn wir in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
gegen die Ukraine kämpfen werden,
lassen Sie uns jetzt über Informationen sprechen,
insbesondere über Geheimdienste. Es ist wichtig
zu verstehen, dass
die USA und auch die NATO unmittelbar nach Beginn des Konflikts damit
begonnen haben, Ukraine Inside zu unterstützen,
indem sie Geheiminformationen bereitgestellt haben
Diese Intelligenz, die es ermöglichte
, die Kommando- und
Kontrollpositionen der russischen Seite anzugreifen und
den russischen Generälen hohe Verluste zuzufügen
, bedeutet, dass den Russen
nicht nur Infanterie fehlte, sondern sie
hatten auch die hohen Verluste, die natürlich
ihre Art der Kriegsführung beeinträchtigten On  Die
Ukrainer der anderen Seite konnten durch den Einsatz von mehreren
tausend Drohnen ein sehr
gutes Situationsbewusstsein haben, und
diese Drohnen wurden nicht nur
zum Zielen auf bestimmte Vermögenswerte der russischen
Seite verwendet, sondern sie wurden auch auf bewaffnete
Weise zum Abwerfen von Munition und Munition eingesetzt  Natürlich,
um der russischen Seite Schaden zuzufügen,
können wir daraus schließen, dass eigentlich der
Begriff Geheimdienst th ist  Die
wichtigste aller verschiedenen Fähigkeiten,
denn es ist entscheidend zu verstehen,
wo der Feind ist und wo
wir Ihre Ressourcen einsetzen müssen, um den Feind anzugreifen und zu treffen.
Lassen Sie uns jetzt über das Konsultieren von Kommando und Kontrolle sprechen,
damit wir sehen können, dass es zwei gibt  Dinge,
die hier wichtig sind, sind
erstens die Art und Weise, Truppen zu führen und Führung,
und das andere ist natürlich die
Kommunikation. Wir wissen, dass die
Ukrainer mit Starlink
bis heute sehr
schnell und erfolgreich kommunizieren konnten, und wir wissen es auch
dass die Art und Weise, wie die Ukrainer
in den letzten Jahren ausgebildet wurden und die
Soldaten ausgebildet wurden, sehr erfolgreich war, weil
sie verstanden haben, dass das Missionskommando
ein sehr sehr wichtiges Führungsgut ist,
auf der anderen Seite arbeitet die russische
Führung sehr zentralisiert, so dass es
immer eine Weile dauert, bis die Situation zustande kommt
und Gewahrsein vom Boden aus
erreicht tatsächlich die höhere Ebene, aber wenn die
höhere Ebene eine klare Vorstellung vom
Verstehen hat, dann natürlich
ihre Truppen so führen können, dass es
erfolgreich ist, haben wir gesehen, wenn wir
uns die Situation in Carson ansehen, die
ein bisschen wie Dünkirchen im Jahr 1914 aussieht,
wo die Russen
30 000 Soldaten und zweieinhalbtausend
Sprecher abziehen konnten  die andere Seite,
ohne von der ukrainischen Seite angegriffen zu werden,
so dass Sie sich fragen könnten, woher
diese Einschätzungen kommen, ist
dies eine Einschätzung unserer Abteilung oder
stammt sie aus anderen Quellen, und
natürlich aus anderen Quellen, an die ich mich
jetzt eigentlich gewöhnt habe  Ich gebe Ihnen den Auftrag, also
gibt es zwei bestimmte
Papiere, auf die ich wirklich hinweisen möchte.
Postpapiere, die für
die Präsentationen verwendet werden, stammen vom Royal
United Service Institute für Verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitsstudien
die
ersten Monate des Konflikts, wenn es
um die russische Invasion geht, und der
andere betrachtet zusätzlich die
Leistung der russischen Luftwaffe  Ich
habe Zitate der ukrainischen Chefin des
Kanalstabs Valerie Solution und
des US-Vorsitzenden der China Chiefs von
Shroff Mark Miley und natürlich des
estnischen Chefs des Militärgeheimdienstes verwendet,
also sagte er, wenn Sie
möchten, dass die Ukraine wieder dazu in der
Lage sein wird  Um eine neue Offensive zu starten,
brauche ich weitere 300 Panzer, 600 bis 700
Schützenpanzer und 500
Artilleriegeschütze,
und Mark Miley sagte nach Kerson, dass
beide Seiten 100.000 Tote
und Verwundete verloren haben, und er war
der Erste, der das sagte  und er sagte auch,
Carson sei eine Möglichkeit, miteinander zu sprechen,
und Großberg, Carl Grosbeck, sagte, dass die
russischen Fähigkeiten immer noch hoch sind und
es noch viel gibt, was sie
im Konflikt verwenden können, um die
Aussagen zusammenzufassen, aus denen ich das
folgende Zitat verwenden möchte  in einem der russi-
dokumente
gibt es die wahrnehmung, dass die streitkräfte
der russischen föderationen
systematisch inkompetent sind,
dass ihre waffen unwiederbringlich korrumpiert sind  dass die Waffen
ineffektiv und unzuverlässig sind und dass
die Truppe nicht in der Lage ist, dieses Narrativ anzupassen,
ist gefährlich,
sowohl weil es ungenau ist als auch
weil es Selbstgefälligkeit fördert,
so dass ich hier betonen möchte, dass
es nicht hilfreich ist zu sagen, dass die
Russen nicht in der Lage sind zu kämpfen  einen Krieg, weil
wir verstehen müssen, dass die Ukraine, wenn
sie den Krieg gewinnen will, weitere
Unterstützung braucht, um gegen die russische Seite zu kämpfen
Ich werde Ihnen zwei Beispiele geben, die
Ihnen eine Vorstellung davon geben,
was das Problem zwischen
dem Wunsch und der Realität ist. Ab Juni haben
wir hier also eines, das besagt, dass die Schläge
der russischen Seite keine nennenswerten
Auswirkungen auf den Konflikt und die russischen
Bestände an präzisen Lenkwaffen haben
nachdem es im Dezember stark erschöpft war
, sieht es ganz anders aus,
denn hier sehen wir,
dass die Russen die
Stromverteilung ins Visier nehmen  Netzwerk
und sie sind in der Lage, die ukrainische Luftverteidigung zu überwältigen oder
zumindest zu versuchen,
und dies hat zur Folge, dass sie versuchen,
die Moral der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung zu untergraben und natürlich die kritische Infrastruktur zu zerstören,
und wie Präsident Zelenski erst kürzlich
im November sagte, dass sie es tun  wurden bereits
über 4 700 Raketen gegen die
kritische Infrastruktur in der Ukraine und
Ziele in der Ukraine eingesetzt, und die
Zahl liegt derzeit bei etwa 5000 Plus,
und während wir über die
Fähigkeiten der russischen Seite diskutieren,
versucht das russische Militär, uns zu beeinflussen
, indem es die Informationen dominiert  Domain
und was sie tun, ist, indem sie viele
verschiedene Medien und natürlich
soziale Medien nutzen, um zu einem
Nebel des Krieges beizutragen, der es sehr schwierig macht
, die aktuelle Situation zu verstehen. Der
Konflikt,
nun die Frage am Ende, die gestellt werden soll
ist okay was noch fehlt
speziell für die ukraine einblick und
wo stehen wir im konflikt und es ist
interessant dass w  Wir können bestimmte
Fragen stellen und versuchen, diese Fragen selbst zu beantworten,
und dann wissen Sie,
wo wir in dem Konflikt stehen, also müssen
wir uns als erstes fragen,
warum es so ist, dass die amerikanische
Seite nur 20 Heima-
Systeme geliefert hat und vielleicht  weitere 18 in den nächsten
Monaten und Jahren und nicht 50 und
100, wie die Ukrainer sagten,
warum die amerikanische Seite nicht
Kämpfer wie F-16 oder sogar A10
geliefert hat, mehr reden und warum sie keinen
Angriff geliefert haben, kommt also das bedeutet a  Raketen
mit größerer Distanz und Reichweite auf der
anderen Seite lieferten sie bereits eine
Patriot-Batterie und auch die Deutschen
werden eine liefern, aber zwei Patriot-
Batterien reichen nicht aus, um den
Luftraum der Ukraine im Innern gegen
diese strategischen Angriffe der Russen zu verteidigen
und eine Sache, die  Viel diskutiert
wird die Lieferung von schweren Waffen wie
Panzern und Schützenpanzern und
natürlich, wie wir
aus den Aussagen der letzten Tage wissen, werden die
Amerikaner liefern  er 50 Bradleys und
die Deutschen 40 Märtyrer-
Schützenpanzer und natürlich sagten die Briten
schon, sie werden 10 Herausforderungen liefern
und vielleicht werden auch die Polen und die
Finnen weitere 20
Leoparden-Sachen liefern, aber jetzt vergleichen wir
noch einmal, was zur allgemeinen Lösung
gesagt wurde  und was sagt uns diese Zahl
über die Situation? Allgemeine Lösung
Er sagte, ich brauche 300 Panzer, 6 bis
700 Schützenpanzer und 500
Artilleriesysteme, und jetzt haben wir hier
30 Panzer und etwa 90 Schützenpanzer,
also können wir hier sehen, dass es einen gibt
Unterschied zwischen diesen Zahlen,
also was als nächstes auf der taktischen Ebene kommt, ist
es wichtig zu verstehen, dass die
Russen versuchen, immer mehr
Kräfte hereinzubringen, um zu versuchen, die Reservekräfte so einzusetzen,
dass sie sie tatsächlich entlang
der gesamten Front einsetzen können, insbesondere in a  Verteidigungshaltung,
so dass wir sehen, dass immer mehr
Russen auf die
andere Seite drängen, wir sehen immer noch, dass es
Lücken gibt, wenn man die vergleicht  Anzahl
gepanzerter Panzerfahrzeuge und sogar
Artilleriesysteme und dass Russland immer noch
versucht, so viel wie möglich hereinzubringen
, was bedeutet, dass die Ukraine
mehr Ausrüstung braucht, um diesen
russischen Angriffen auf taktischer Ebene entgegenzuwirken,
wenn es um die operative Ebene
geht, ist es wichtig  Um zu verstehen, dass
alle eingehenden Geräte
von den Ukrainern verwendet werden, um zwei Elemente in Kerngröße zu bilden,
eines im Bereich von
Polterva und das andere in den Bereichen
von drei, drei Vorfeldern,
Superrussland. Der eine Kern nach der Inszenierung ist derjenige,
der es ist  könnte Direction angreifen
und vielleicht die Versorgungsleitungen,
die aus Russland in Tombas kommen, unterbrechen.
Das andere Kernelement könnte aus dem
Saporoshi-Gebiet
angreifen
erfolgreich, weil
dies nicht nur hohe Verluste auf
russischer Seite verursachen, sondern auch die
russischen Truppen auf Cri isolieren würde  Meine Unterstützung und
natürlich Castle,
was können Sie auf strategischer Ebene erwarten?
Auf der einen Seite haben die Ukrainer
versucht, die kritische
Infrastruktur mit den notwendigen Mitteln der
Luftverteidigung zu verteidigen, aber auf der anderen Seite
versuchen die Ukrainer auch,
die Räume anzugreifen, in denen die Strategischen  Bomber
oder gar die Schiffe stationiert
sind, die die Träger von
Marschflugkörpern sind, die in der Ukraine hohe Verluste
anrichten, und was Sie hier erwarten können, ist,
dass wir weitere Angriffe auf die
Ukraine im Inneren auch tief im Land
in Russland
mit dem Ziel sehen werden  tatsächlich diese
strategischen Vermögenswerte von russischer Seite getroffen
haben, war
schon am Anfang klar, dass dieser
Konflikt ein Zermürbungskrieg ist
, was
für viele Experten lange Zeit nicht akzeptiert wurde, aber es
ist tatsächlich der Fall, den wir sehen können
Wenn wir uns dieses Bild ansehen,
zeigt dieses Bild ein Gelände in der Nähe
von
Parkmut  Was wir hier von den Wagner-Truppen
sehen können, ist, dass wir
einen Krieg führen, von dem wir nicht
erwarten, dass er in naher Zukunft kommt, und
es ist ein Krieg, der Sie an die
Situation im Ersten Weltkrieg erinnert, und wie
Sie hier sehen können  Das Problem ist, dass auf der
einen Seite die russischen Standorte immer noch
zu wenig Infanterie haben, was
es ihnen erschwert, die
ukrainischen Stellungen anzugreifen, und auf der anderen
Seite die Ukrainer das
Dilemma haben, dass sie das Gelände halten müssen,
weil sie es teilen wollen
Die Russen besetzen diese bestimmten
und strategischen Geländemerkmale, was
bedeutet, dass wir immer noch einen Krieg haben, der
auch in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten mit Artillerie ausgetragen wird.
Die Frage ist jetzt, wer die längere
Brise hat, damit wir wissen, dass die ukrainische
Seite stark ist  insbesondere von
den Vereinigten Staaten geliefert wird und die europäischen
Nationen bereits darum kämpfen,
mehr Ausrüstung auf der anderen Seite einzuführen, wissen wir,
dass die russische Seite bereits mit der
Produktion begonnen hat  e insbesondere militärische
Ausrüstung und dass sie
immer mehr moderne Mittel wie
den T90-Panzer einführen, den wir
in den kommenden Wochen auch bereits an der Front gesehen haben,
daher möchte ich Ihnen mitteilen,
dass es noch nicht vorbei ist  und dass wir
in naher Zukunft mit weiteren Überraschungen rechnen
können, müssen wir auch ein wenig auf all
die anderen Nationen schauen, die in diesem Konflikt eine Rolle spielen
, nicht nur hinter der Ukraine,
wie die Vereinigten Staaten, natürlich die
europäischen Nationen oder einige andere
bedeutende Akteure, sondern  Auch wenn es
um Russland und Staaten wie China, den
Iran oder sogar Indien geht, ist der Konflikt in einfachen Worten
wie beim Boxen, wir haben
zwei Seiten, die gegeneinander kämpfen, die
ukrainische Seite und die russische Seite.
Mehrere Runden sind bereits passiert, die
meisten dieser Runden wurden von gewonnen
Ukraine drinnen, aber es ist noch offen, wie sich
die nächsten Runden entwickeln werden
, ob es in naher Zukunft ein KO gibt oder ob
es andere Überraschungen gibt, werden die
Russen auch das nächste r bestehen  Das
sind die Fragen, die wir
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten beantworten
müssen, die mein heutiges Briefing abschließen.
Ich möchte mich
ganz herzlich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit bedanken und am Ende
und natürlich am Anfang dieses
Jahres möchte ich mich bedanken  Hoffen wir mal auf
eine schnelle Lösung dieses Konflikts